this is a brand new trend it's called
vabbing all right this is like going
around to talk
at the gym
vibing at the gym for the first time
you guys aren't gonna believe me okay
now i'm in the sauna but it worked the
vibing worked
so just based off that alone what do you
think vabbing is
i mean i have no [ __ ] she says i'm
vaping at the gym and then she goes at
work the vabbing was successful
if you had to guess
no no
something to do with the vagina
yes
because vag is in there yeah and these
women aren't creative enough to think of
a new term you know what i mean so
you're on it uh vaginal what
mark any idea
miles any idea uh vibrating this is
basically a new phenomenon where women
are mixing in their vaginal fluids
either with perfume or just going
straight raw dog and putting it on like
their neck in their hair on their right
dabbing like perfume perfume
as a way to spread their pheromones and
attract men in a more natural way
it doesn't matter how much [ __ ] juice
that woman puts on that [ __ ] calzone
of the neck of hers
i'm not
i am not hitting her there is that
girl's out of her mind she's sitting
there going first of all you're not
going to the gym they're like don't
don't don't even don't even start with
that i was at the gym what's she wearing
first of all can we re-watch that video
i'm not gonna play it again i've refused
okay no dude yeah yeah
yeah and this is bad now you have like
younger women are gonna look at this and
they're gonna be like throwing [ __ ]
juice all over their necks and [ __ ]
why is this bad
she fully dressed in the sauna so yeah
what the [ __ ] is going on she's fully
dressed in the song maybe because she
doesn't go to the gym that often she
doesn't know how to dress in the sun
yeah come on maybe just to sweat as much
as humanly possible yeah stop it this is
this is the whole thing people are doing
this all over the country this is cap
yeah i don't believe what i mean it's
cap it's happening this woman is doing
it right there
okay but is it how how do we know it's
working she's by herself in a sauna
saying it worked why wouldn't it work
okay the pheromones hold on if you can
smell them
you're going to be uh you're going to be
drawn to it i don't know if you will 100
we're not just drawing pheromones like
we have eyes dudes
people act like pheromones as a love
potion it's not it can heighten some
stuff but that's it have you ever heard
that [ __ ] though where like they gave
woman a bunch of samples a t-shirt smell
all the shirts whichever shirt
which one do you think smells the best
and then they did like a blind test on
which guy they thought was most tragic
there was a correlation between like the
shirt smell and the guy i believe
there's a correlation
but again if i saw her
look at him he looks like if no jason
said that you should ask him
no i actually think that's interesting i
like experiments like that like that's a
more like sophisticated version of
astrology right so instead of like uh
you were born on this day and your sun
rising and that kind of [ __ ] you uh
you're seeing who you're naturally
attracted to now are we naturally
attracted to
a um a smell or scent or are we
naturally attracted to an ability to
protect and provide and the
the
physiology and biology of someone that
can do those things for example like do
women like a taller guy because they
think oh you could probably protect me a
little bit more like is that override
the smell i think a attraction up is
physical first like how you look
appearance and then it goes to this
other stuff heightens it pheromones
that's when you really connect with
somebody yeah yeah when the pheromones
line up first i think they're cute then
they got the pheromones popping we match
up now we're in in in now this this is
this is a
this sounds like a a bit
like and it is like something that i
thought of in that regard i might even
try it on stage but like
i think that
if women are sexually attracted like
they are turned on
by different things than us then sexual
harassment from them should be adjusted
for example if a woman is that's a great
bit into tall guys yeah right if a girl
goes how tall are you that's sexual
harassment that is akin to a guy asking
about a girl doing what [ __ ] uh the
guy did aoc yeah yeah yeah like if
you're just seeing guys go oh you're so
tall that's your big booty latina yeah
you're a big boy
me right that's great so because you're
not into physical looks in the same way
that we are you [ __ ] creep yeah
you're korean
what do you mean i was this tall when
you [ __ ] saw me laugh like what are
you yeah
but isn't there something to that like
like what do you do for a living asking
a guy what you do for a living knowing
full well that a certain profession
might be attractive to you biologically
not saying you're some [ __ ] gold
digger at all i'm saying like you your
loins are craving a man who can protect
you when you have a kid and you can't
work
you're loins
okay if you ask about my job
what's up with the aerios
shouldn't isn't that that's the quality
that's true he's able to come right back
with that what are you doing for a
living yeah how big your titties kev big
kev hold on you know how often he gets
asked how tall are you by which it's
unbelievable no dude ass no dude i don't
care exactly how tall you yeah you
talked it was the first thing i asked
when i saw him
[Laughter]
i thought i asked his profession i was
like do you play basketball please
that's my second question
it's like a shoot video for akash
were you dying to ask that question
someone who wasn't black finally yes you
play basketball seriously
finally i can ask a white guy i cannot
be racist as connecticut yeah dude i
like being white basketball players too
those are like my heroes
because they're overcoming adversity you
know yeah that's true yeah that's true
that's like that tosh bit where he's
like dude white players should their
points should count one extra why
because it's like
he has a bunch of justifications for it
but he's like yeah it's like it's harder
for them to score points so you might as
well add a point to every basket they
make and then on top of that it proves
to black people that uh white people are
gonna always earn more than them
you know tosh is the goat dude we gotta
get tosh on the podcast i would love
that we gotta get i would love that he's
great yeah he's a [ __ ] beast